Republicans are now going to investigate
the January 6th investigation what yeah
we knew they would do it the last
Congress saw the House of
Representatives January 6th committee
that was a committee which investigated
the Trump riots Republicans for a long
time have been saying the committee is
the problem the committee has committed
wrongdoing and now as expected there is
going to be an investigation of the
investigation NBC news reports
Republicans launch an investigation into
the January 6th committee
that examined the riot Congressman Barry
Loudermilk from Georgia will lead the
investigation and was accused by The
house's former January 6th panel of
giving tours of the capital in the days
leading up to the riot so individuals
whose connection to the riots
is at minimum
raising some red flags
are going to be doing the investigating
into the very committee that looked at
some of their own actions this is an
infinite regression to some degree but
it is also maybe one of the most bad
faith investigations that Republicans
want to take on the article goes on to
say many House Republicans were vocal
critics since the creation of the
January 6 committee yeah we know
uh the inquiry seems to make good on
lawmaker campaign Trail vows to
investigate the investigators Now
understand this will go nowhere this is
going to go absolutely nowhere I know
that I get some of these emails from the
right and see some comments on the
YouTube channel about oh we're gonna put
we're gonna put Adam Schiff in prison
for that January 6th committee Jamie
raskins going to be locked up for the
Gen no they're not nobody's going to be
locked up it was a completely reasonable
well-organized well it was actually one
of the best investigative Endeavors that
I've seen the House of Representatives
undertake uh in at least a decade but
they need to Virtue signal they need to
show that we are going to do the thing
and it'll sort of end with a Fizz rather
than a bang
um and nothing will happen
um a couple of other notes about this
CNN report some additional details House
Republicans plot new January 6th probes
despite internal backlash over Kevin
McCarthy giving Tucker Carlson footage
so this is the background to Republicans
saying we're going to investigate that
January 6th Committee in the background
Republicans are only raising new reasons
why they should be the ones investigated
and most recently it is uh Kevin
McCarthy handing over previously
unreleased footage from the January 6th
Insurrection Riot call it what you want
to Tucker Carlson to Fox News
propagandist Tucker Carlson we now know
of course that Tucker Carlson turned
that around and used the footage to try
to claim falsely by the way that the
entire story we were told about January
6 was wrong even many Republicans in
responding to Tucker Carlson's bogus
narrative that he has played out on
National Television I believe it was
Monday and Tuesday of this week even
many Republicans have said Tucker's
conclusions Tucker's narrative based on
the footage that he aired doesn't
actually follow from the footage so this
is the latest thing it will probably end
you know to people like you and I we see
this stuff and we say wow humiliating
endless resources spent The Virtue
signaling and the mouth flapping and the
entire thing and of course they come up
with nothing it's like Durham Trump
waiting around for months if not years
Durham Durham's going to expose all the
things Democrat
nothing came of it nothing came of it
and that's why these investigations are
very loudly announced and then they end
with a Fizz because there's really
nothing there if anything we need a new
January 6th committee investigating the
alleged and arguable Republican cover-up
of January 6th that even includes these
recent things over the last few months
what will actually happen uh as the
day-to-day uh and what confrontations
were will there be or what would the
hearings be like we'll just have to wait
and see but I am not a betting man but I
would be willing to bet here nothing
substantive comes of the investigation
into the investigation if you disagree
with me if you think that the January
6th committee did something wrong or
whatever the case may be let me know in
a comment let me know in an email I'd be
interested in hearing from you